nun möchte wissen was sagst du zu
fahrrad und kollegah und zu jbg 2 also
ich freue mich auf jeden fall die jungs
sehr gut der junge hat er sich redlich
verdient jungs machen ihr ding respekt
jewgeni knaup fragt wirst du wie zum
beispiel bushido und sido einen film
drehen oder wie manche andere rapper ein
buch schreiben oder willst du nur lieder
aufnehmen was hältst du davon
also im moment mache ich mir nicht so
gedanken darüber ein film zu drehen oder
ein buch zu schreiben im moment nicht
nur musik machen aber diese gedanken mit
dem buch du weißt die geschichte von
assisi die muss auch noch mal verfilmt
werden wenn man aber im moment liegt der
fokus ganz klar auf mucke mohammad nabi
meint alter ego oder meter waren deine
beiden besten alben und heute reist du
sehr verweichlicht wie kommt es dazu
momentan werde bildung und pax an filter
den krieg großväter den frieden raus
macht lust drauf hast entwickelt sich
weiter bleibt mich stehen in seiner
entwicklung um wörter alter ego freut
mich dass dir die alben gefallen
präsidieren und japans talfahrt wann
gehst du endlich mal an die handynummer
die du in deinem track molotow
veröffentlicht dass daran eine gute
frage wenn ich dann mal ran gehen ganz
ehrlich ich bin die erste woche lang
habe ich die sind nur noch frei gehalten
und bin ganz heran gegangen aber es geht
einfach nicht mehr ich hab versucht
wirklich so viele anrufer wie möglich
einfach mal cool kurz einmal hallo zu
sagen was geht ab groß anrufst klagt
wieder aufgelegt wie leute dann sich
auch kurz gefolgt von selbst so ok
mach's gut auch ein koloss dran gern
aber ich habe es einfach nicht mehr ich
kann nicht kann ich mein leben lang mit
euch reden das ist thema zur musik
machen aber cool hast du das abgecheckt
hass und gegen hewitt hat die frage
fahrt welche deutschen rapper kannst du
überhaupt nicht leiden
musik mäßig also deutsche rapper finde
ich auf jeden fall scheiße finde ich
jugendtreffs heino finde ich nicht gut
als rapper will ich noch nicht gut
grönemeyer ist auch ein grönemeyer finde
ich auch nicht gut als rapper aber als
musiker finde ich ihn sehr gut
das ding ist wenn ich als rapper
überhaupt nicht leiden kann es wirklich
da da fällt mir einer vom kopf weil
dafür in die krone vom kopf ist jan
delay also das gibt
das geht überhaupt nicht die ganzen
ganze jahr erkältet so was ist